that's
awes who's the
just
okay so I'm going to start the next four
sessions with the same two questions and
if you've been in my corporate finance
class you know what the questions are
going to be here's the first one how
many of you have picked a company to
Value as you can see most of you haven't
that question will get reframed next
week the question I'm going to ask is
how many of you have not picked a
company because I'd like the numbers to
kind of shift which is the rest of you
right
now don't wait around don't try to find
the perfect company there are 48,000
company don't tell me you can't find a
company right don't look for other
people to give you just pick a damn
company and get started and if you
change your mind you can always go
change the company so if you've picked
the company the followup question is
have you gone into the master list and
entered your company name please do so
again you're not bound by it you can go
back and change that company name if you
want to this is just for me to get a
sense that you actually are doing doing
something so at least do it for me so
after you pick a company go on and put
your name on
yes nothing so don't fill out somebody
try to fill out all the rest of the
cells if you do the rest of the class
becomes moot right this is at the moment
all you've done is picked a company it's
a blank slate so the rest of that
spreadsheet will get filled out over the
course of the Class
by no
no it actually will be worse because
then you picking the company for the
wrong reasons right you're picking it
because you want to know a segment
knowing where you might want to work
might be relevant right because you
might want to understand the business
you're in so if you're going to go work
in Pharmaceuticals I my suggestion is
pick a pharmaceutical company you're
going to work in technology so it's not
what you want to learn out of this
because you will always learn from any
company you pick pick something but most
critically pick a company you're
interested in right pick something that
you always wondered why right tomorrow's
uh valuation of the week is going to be
inidia you got my advanced notice with
the Deep seek post but you know it will
be about Nvidia and I want you to
wrestle with Nvidia because face the
entire it's not just we're all
interested in Nidia where entire Market
is waiting with baited breath on what
will Nvidia
do so with that out of the way let me
get started with the start of the class
as I said every session will start with
this so let's start with today's start
of the classes it's about consistency in
cash flows we set the table we haven't
done this yet but you sit down to value
a business you have to make a choice
what is that choice you have to decide
whether you want to Value just the
equity in the business or value the
entire business sounds like I'm playing
on words but let's start a business you
guys are going to be Equity investors
you guys are going to be lenders I raise
money from you in the form of debt I
raise Equity from you and this can be a
private company or a public company it
doesn't matter private company just
equity in its unnamed form in a public
company will'll be buying shares so I've
raiseed 100 million from debt 150
million from Equity I start the
business Factory platform let's say the
business starts working cash flow start
to come in who gets first claim on the
cash
flows interest in principal payments and
if there is any cash left over there's
no guarantee there will be I
might give it back to you why might
because there's no contractual
requirement that I return the cash I
might pay a dividend I might buy back
stock if it's a publicly or I might just
hold the cash for you even though I
forget sometimes that it's for you I
think it's for me but it's for
you the bottom line is as a business I
generate cash flows for both of
you in in valuation you got to make a
choice early on are you going to focus
just on the equity investors and
discount the cash flows that Equity
investors get so you guys are the
lenders I'm not going to look at you
Equity investors take the cash flows you
get as leftover cash flows and
discounted back at the rate of
return you would demand for call this a
cost of equity but let's strip it down
to Basics you didn't invest in My Equity
because you felt sorry for me I hope you
invested because you wanted to make a
return right 12% 50 you know the cost of
equity is it's that number that you had
in your head and already you can see
this is going to be a nightmare to
estimate why because it's in your head
unlike the L who puts an interest rate
on the loan this is something in your
head we we'll talk about what INF
Finance we do to kind of get around that
problem cash flows to equity discounted
the cost of equity is the value of
equity in a
business of course if you're an equity
investor in a publicly traded company
the only tangible cash flow you get from
the company is
what
dividends everything else is kind of
waving hands free cash flow I can
computer and paper Dividends are the own
it's a check in the in the mail or
deposit in your bank the dividend
discount model is a special case of an
equity valuation model why special
because we
know conclusively that companies don't
pay out what they can afford to in
dividends we'll talk about why we know
it so
conclusively they hold back cash they
pay out too much in in dividends so
we'll talk about an alternative way of
estimated cash flows is potential div
for those of you not corporate finance
class we attach an acronym to it do you
remember what the acronym was let's see
how much Corporate Finance you still
remember Michael you remember referring
to free cash flow Equity free cash flow
equity which is basically cash left over
after you met every conceivable need
right cash flows Equity discounted the
cost of equity a value of equity but
there's another way I could have
approached valuation that requires a
little bit of an intuitive Le I got
capital from both of you right equity
and lenders What if I thought of both of
you as capital providers and look at the
collective cash flow you get from the
business that's going to be cash flow
Equity plus the cash flows to debt that
Collective cash flow is called free cash
flow to the firm it's a pre- debt cash
flow because lenders are now players in
this game they're Capital providers
they're not Outsiders if that is the
cash flow I'm discounting not the cash
flow Equity but the collective cash flow
I can no longer discount that cash flow
at the cost of equity I've got to
discounted at some weighted average if
this is starting to sound familiar it
should if it isn't sounding familiar
then you might have some issues with
your corporate finance class if I take
the cost of equity and the cost of debt
and I take a weighted average what is
pleas let's let's call it cost of
capital wax sounds so crude let's call
it cost of capital but it's a weighted
average cost of capital basic so if you
have cash flows the entire firm the
discount rate you should apply is the
cost of cap consist y rule one in
discounted cash flow valuation you
cannot mix and match you tell me how you
estimate cash flows I'll tell you what
the discount rate should be do you think
people break this rule all the
time and people who should know better
or perhaps know nothing at all so I'm
going to for today's class talk about
what ends up happening in practice so
I'm going to take you back all the way
to the late 70s
company called kott it's a copper mining
company sold off a piece of its business
called peab body coal because the
antitrust laws kicked in they were
forced to sell it and when they sold PE
body coal they got $600 million in cash
from that sale and it created an
immediate problem for kott kott was a
three billion doll company 600 million
is 20% of the company's cash and they
were worried they being the manag of the
company what do you think they were
worried about scotlet what would I
thought having a lot of cash was good
why might managers be worried about
having a lot of cash what would they
worried about you
think which is fine so you share so you
know that is easy to fix right just make
sure it's inves in something safe and
riskless so investing cash and Tes is
always a safe way to go if that were the
problem it's easy to fix but what else
does having a lot of
cash they were worried about a hostile
quisition you're saying why would having
a lot of cash in your balance sheet make
you a better Target for hostile acquis
because you made the acquired job a lot
easier right because when they buy your
company they can use your cash to pay
for some of the proceeds so you got 600
million in cash you don't have a need
for what's the most sensible way to get
rid of this
problem give it back to the shareholders
right but what would they do stupid
things like paying off their mortgages
and paying for car expenses and no you
couldn't allow that so they went for the
second so the that's a the most sensible
way they went for the stupidest way to
get rid of 600 million which is spend it
quickly so they went to First Boston at
that time the leading m&a back on Wall
Street and they said we have 600 million
cash we want to spend the cash can you
help
us what do you think the answer was oh
of course we
can and a couple of weeks later first
Boston came back with the perfect Target
company Perfect in what sense you could
buy for exactly 600 million which works
out to be coincidentally the cash you
told me you had on your balance sheet
rule number one the value of a Target
company will magically expand to fill in
whatever cash you have on your balance
sheet now do you see why Tim Cook never
asked anybody I 250 billion in
cash can you help me spend the cash
there will be a $250 billion company
you're paying for I'm going to show you
the valuation they use because even
banks have to have a fig Leaf when they
say you can pay 600 million right they
have to show that what you're getting is
worth more than 650 million these are
the cash flows that first Boston used to
justify paying 600
million I want you to focus on how the
cash flows are estimated because I'm
going to have a question to you at the
end of what is the right discount rate
to apply on this cash flows so what
first Boston did was it projected the
revenues the target company is a company
called car brandom it's abrasives
company know make sandpaper metallic
abrasives they projected the revenues
the expenses came up with operating
income kept going subtracted interest
expenses to come up with net income they
added depreciation subtracted capex even
debt repayments were paid off and they
came up with the cash flow so I want to
think about what I did to get to the
cash flow cuz here comes the question
I'm going to give you six different
discount rates I could use only one of
them is the right one let's see if you
can narrow down which of these six
discount rates should be used to
Discount these cash flows you got the
acquiring company which is kenot you got
the target company which is carbar
rendom you'll have a merge company
afterwards Cara kenot if you want to
call that right you can have the cost of
equity for each of these companies and
the cost of capital so let's start easy
give given how I just estimated cash
flows should I be using a cost of equity
or a cost of
capital and why would I use the cost of
equity
anybody because you made adjustments for
debt because I computed cash flows are
one of the deadliest giveaways of what
your cash flows are if you start with
net income you probably dug yourself
into a hole already because net income
is after expenses and you're doing this
right and you do Debt Pay it's a cash
flow Equity so that actually do is good
because we got rid of one column right
so it's not the cost of capital that we
cost now
comes to me the central question m&a and
those of you are planning to go to m&a
if you get this question wrong please
reconsider anybody want to go into
m&a okay you'll be my
m&a Guinea pay right so we've decided
cost of equity who cost of equity
acquired
company Target company or merge company
are Target Target everybody agree with
that I'll play Devil's Advocate who's
coming up with the
money the acquiring company
right why shouldn't I use my cost of
equity it's my my shareholders money why
wouldn't I use it because the cash FL
I'm getting is
theet it goes back to a first principle
in capital budgeting the discount rate
for a project should reflect the risk of
the project not the risk of the entity
looking at the project it's a it's a
lesson we forget very quickly because
you have the stupid thing like called a
corporate hurdle rate the minute you do
that you've lost your senses because you
think the cost of capital is a cost of
raising money the cost of capital and
valuation has nothing to do with you
raising money it's got everything to do
with the rate of return you can earn on
an equivalent investment it's a Target
companies's cost of equi which in this
case would have been
16.5% Coen what's the worst possible
choice you could have made in
here cost of
capital Bingo that's exactly what first
Boston used they used the cost of
capital of the acquiring firm using some
stupid logic first mixing up equity and
capital right acting like they in and
then this acquiring company argument
you're saying what's the big deal 10 1
12% versus 162% using a 10 a half% cost
of capital would have given you a value
of about 750 million which makes a 600
million perfectly reasonable right
taking their cash flows I'm not even
contesting a single cash flow using the
right discount rate on it you'd have
ended up with $450 million now what have
you asked your client to do go pay 600
million for something that you actually
have valued at 4 50 million and for this
you get banking
fees could have asked my doorman what
should I pay for this company probably
got better
advice he saying how did this come out
here's what happened first B thought it
had done this right it gave the numbers
to a Harvard Business School professor
and every Harvard Business School
becomes a strategy case this became a
strategy case we about right fit and
wrong fit this was an exhibit you're not
even supposed to pay attention to it
this this was the only thing in the
entire case to me that I paid attention
to because the rest was dressing up a
turkey there's really nothing to
do this is valuation
101 and guess who the co-heads for first
Boston's m&a Department were the late
70s Bruce Wastin and Joe Pella remember
the was Su par because their punishment
for this kind of
malpractice was they created a
boutique Investment Bank God only knows
what the boutique there means you know
pricing margins
higher and they did more of this
valuation malpractice for 10 years and
the way they got punished for doing that
was Dresner Bank actually paid $2
billion to acquire was perella for their
valuation expertise that's exactly how
the Pres I can't even make this stuff
up there's no justice in this world but
the lesson I wanted to take away from
this is not specifically about this
particular case but to think about when
you see a name on the top of a valuation
Goldman Sachs KKR what do you assume
they must know what they're doing
don't I've seen valuation teams and
practice I know exactly why this happens
there's probably one team in one room
working on the cash flow there another
team in the other room working in the
discount rate and never the twain shall
meet 11 57 p.m. and midnight is your
deadline or midday is your 12:00 p.m. is
your deadline you got 3 minutes to bring
it all together who's asking the big
questions about what cash flows are you
estimating right it happens far too
frequently so consistency in cash flows
we've come up the first step we're going
to add more consistency test remember
the consistency fact so with that out of
the way let's go back and finish up that
first intro packet because we have a few
other things to do any question though
because I want you to be ready with this
because half of all m&a valuations that
I see use the wrong companies this
country and once you do that the rest
becomes moot I don't care how well you
estimate cash flows if you
mismatch no you've lost the game already
because if you mismatch you know what's
going to happen right and you're a Safe
Company use your cost of capital to
Value Target companies tell me what
you're going to end up doing friends
if you're a safe company and you keep
using your cost to Capital value risky
companies it's not even that you're
going to buy every risky company is
going to look cheap to you you're going
to buy risk your mistakes are you saying
don't mistakes average are not if
they're all in the One Direction your
mistakes all going to be in the same
direction you're going to overpay for
risky companies over and over
again until you wipe yourself out this
is how AT&T almost destroyed itself as a
company in the 1990
because it used its cost of cap which
was historically low
Marbell to look at Telecom company which
are technology companies coming up that
looks cheap that looks cheap and not
once in this process did somebody
ask are we doing the right
thing so any questions on acquiring
Target companies because we'll come back
to this again in the context of valuing
Acquisitions I left you with the three
ways of attaching a number to an asset I
talked about discounted cash flow
valuation intrinsic valuation you value
an asset put a number on an asset based
on its cash flows growth and
risk having said that though 90% of what
you see out there is pricing what is
pricing in pricing you attach a number
to an asset based on what other people
are paying for similar
assets it's how we put a number on an
apartment or a house when we buy
it in pricing you remember in intrinsic
valuation you kept the Fai like the Holy
Grail there is an intrinsic value I
never get to see it but I'm going to
keep trying I'm going to here you don't
even try he said there's no such thing
as intrinsic value what somebody pays
for something is all that matters and if
you break down pricing down here are the
things you will have as any pricing
first it' be nice if you could find
something exactly like yours that is
priced out there right and if you
do pricing becomes very very simple you
just match up that price that's what you
pay I can almost guarantee that's never
going to be the case you're value
equities in what Universe are you going
to find 15 companies just like Microsoft
or adobe or Nvidia or any company so
what do you do you gather together a
group of companies that you claim are
just like your company I know you're
lying you know you're lying but nobody
pushes too hard this an every Equity
researchable these are the 15 pure group
companies then you recognize very
quickly you can't compare price per
share across companies why
not what's the most expensive company in
the world if price per share were my
metric of expensive
achiev B had to trade 350,000 a share
and a penny stock looks really cheap
right but that makes no sense because
price per share is arbitrary I do a 2
for one stock split in V you did a 1041
stocks like a 90% discount on the price
but don't get too excited it's also 90%
discount the earnings per share and
everything or every other metric so what
do you need to do you need to
standardize the price that's what a
multiple is price earnings evab there's
nothing magical about it using a
standardized price if you're in real
estate what's analogous price per square
foot because you can't compare two
buildings of different
sizes and then if you're careful and
only if you're careful you try to
control for differences why because
remember the 15 companies that you said
were just like yours you wake up and say
Well they're not just like mine
they have higher growth a lower risk and
you try to this is the story of every
pricing are you assuming Market mistakes
well you are but you're also assuming
that markets are right on average do you
see why because where you getting the
pricing for all those other companies
across the market you're saying markets
are right across the 15 companies but
they make mistakes on individual
companies is a very different
perspective on Market mistakes and comes
with an advantage let's say have a steel
company trading at five times earnings
and every other Steel company trades at
15 times earnings it's going to stick
out like a sore thumb right the mistake
is going to be more
visible so what's more likely to happen
remember the correction part it's more
likely to happen in a shorter time frame
with pricing than with intrinsic
valuation because the mistake is out
there for everybody to
see so that's at the basis of pricing
let's take a look at the advantages and
disadvantage advantages and who's best
suited for pricing Advantage pricing
you're always in sync with the market
what does that mean you're never going
to be out of stocks because everything
is
relative 40 times earnings look high to
you but what if everything trades at 50
times earnings it looks cheap so on a
pricing basis there will always be cheap
stocks and that's good for people who
have that as part of their mission
statement let's say you're an equity
fund manager at fidelity
you don't have the luxury of saying
everything is overvalued I'm not buying
it you have to buy stocks you're going
to be using pricing because you have to
buy stocks your your sside equity
research aners what's your job to take
15 companies and tell me which are buys
and which are sells that's a pricing
mission right
there I don't have a problem with equity
research analysts using multiples and
comparables I do have a problem with
them playing Kabuki dances with DCFS and
claiming that their buy came out of d
yeah or a cell let's stop this cover
Story I mean this is a pricing so if
your job requires you to always hold
you're going to essentially be in sync
with the market right it also does mean
that you if a different game to play
right you're trying not to gauge whether
the market is right you're trying to
gauge something about the direction so
if you're a momentum based Trader
pricing is the only game you care
about and at least on the surface
pricing requires less
information than valuation now I've sent
out that that thing about Capital IQ if
you get a chance please get on right
it's a if you want to do a five minute
pricing of Nvidia you can do it in five
minutes it's pull up a multiple for 20
semiconductor companies I don't know how
much you want to do with that pricing
but pricing doesn't require a whole lot
of information at least on the surface
it looks like you don't have to make the
assumptions about cash flow and grow
growth and risk that you do an intrinsic
valuation so those are the advantages
like many equity research anal you ask
them why do you use multiple the answer
is because I don't like all these
assumptions you have to
make about cash flows growth and risk so
in fact I heard from a few saleside
equity research analyst about my Invidia
valuation they said all these
assumptions you're making about size of
the AI Market the market share the
margins I don't have to do any of that
stuff really cuz here are the advantage
of pricing do you really think you're
not making assumptions about growth and
cash flows and margins when you
pay 50
times mean in really I think you're
paying four times revenues or six times
revenues for the company do you think
you Constantine do you think you're
making assumptions about cash flows
growth and risk when you pay 10 times
revenues or 20 times
revenues first on growth are you
assuming high growth or low growth what
kind of margins do you you
probably really high right because so in
a sense you're making assumption they're
just
implicit is the advantage of implicit
assumptions people can't pick it pick
them apart so when you do an intrinsic
valuation say how do you know the AI
Market chip Market is going to be 3 I
don't I estimated it well I didn't have
to you did it implicitly I'd rather make
it explicit and be
wrong then implicitly make an assumption
that I don't even know I'm making so
there's no that you're you're not making
assumptions is a fraud in fact one of
the things we're going to do when we
talk about multiples we're going to take
each multiple and we're going to see
what assumptions you're implicitly
making when you pay three times Book
value or five times revenues or 800
times
earnings second let's be clear here you
know whenever somebody who pricing and
let's all of trading is built on
pricing talks dismissively about Market
efficiency let's be clear that you're
very selective about the market
efficiency you dislike because you just
asum markets are efficient on average
that they make mistakes individually at
least be honest with yourself that
you're assuming market efficiency in
efficiency just like everybody else it's
a it's a type of efficiency or
inefficiency you're assuming and
finally if you create a portfolio based
on underprice stocks not under valued
stocks is it possible that your entire
portfolio could still crash in
Bur so let's say you buy a let's let's
take a sector AI sector you buy
underpriced AI stocks God only knows
what the metrics look like with these
underpriced AI stocks but remember
everything is is relative to the average
so 10 times revenues is lower than 20
times so you
create what's the risk you're exposed to
if the entire AI sector is overpriced
you could be right and the way it will
show up is you lose only 60% of your
portfolio whereas everybody else loses
80% if that's what gives you comfort by
all means go that direction but be at
least aware of what you're getting
you're not getting undervalued companies
you're getting companies that are
underpriced relative to
something so we talk about Advantage
let's talk about who is best Su in doing
first let's look at what kinds of assets
are easiest to price to price something
you need a large number of things at
least remotely like it that are being
traded so they have a price on
them now do you see why when you have to
get a number on fine art or collectible
you have to end up giving 6 or 8% to an
appraiser me you have to price a Picasso
all you have to do is find hundreds of
picassos that got traded last year good
luck with that the last Picasso that
might have been so might have been three
years ago pricing becomes much more
difficult in some asset classes it is
because you don't have much much in
terms of transactions and there has to
be something in common you scale it up
to and this is the other problem let's
say you did find 10 picassos what do you
scale them to the size of the painting I
that's not a very good measure right the
monisa is tiny but it's worth a lot you
know your paintings that are huge that
are not worth that much I'm not even
sure what the stand and that's where the
appraiser says I know I'm the expert I
can look look at the brush strokes and
tell you whether is early pickar or late
pick he could be lying but you have no
idea you pay 8% of the price of the
painting to Christies or whoever else
the auctioneer is pricing becomes
easiest when you have that's why StubHub
and SE geek so works so incredibly well
right and you have you want to buy
tickets to a Taylor Swift concert you're
not sitting there agonizing over am I
comparing Apples to Apples you are
comparing Apples to Apples because they
give you bsection these are the ticket
prices and they even give you I think a
view of what the so you can check the
view so you can see why pricing works
really well in some some some types of
pricing and what kinds of investors can
turn pricing to Advantage first if your
time Horizon is shorter talk about how
pricing corrects more quickly so for a
lot of investors this is this seals the
deal you have 3 month six- Monon time
Horizon you're going to go with
pricing it's nice if you're judged
against other people playing the same
game if you seen Morning Star assign
stars to mutual fund managers you know
how they assign the
Stars what do they
do Alexander what do you think Morning
Star does to give you five stars or
three stars as a mutual fund
manager and compare it to
they look at other portfolio managers
who are in so they basically have these
nine boxes that they which are you know
people swim around the boxes all the
time based on value or market cap and
you say you're a small cap value mutual
fund manager these are what other small
cap mutual fund managers did and if they
were down 15% and you're down
10% you have three star four stars even
five stars see what I mean by measured
you're not measured against an absolute
you're not measured against do you make
money it's you measured against other
people and much of portfolio management
is that dance and here's what finally
seems today when you price things you
can find them underpriced or overpriced
if you're a
Fidelity or a t price it's only the
underpriced the draw attention
why cuz as mutual funds are long only
they can only buy they can't sell
short wouldn't it be nice if you could
take if you're a good pricer wouldn't it
be nice if you could take advantage of
both underpriced and overpriced because
then you don't even have to be right
about Market Direction it's a correction
towards what you think is so who am I
talking about Bradley can who can take
advantage of both underpriced and
overpriced hedge funds if hedge funds
actually behave like hedge funds a lot
of hedge funds dance a game they really
say I'm a hedge fund but look at them
all the positions are long wrong only
say what makes you a hedge fund but in
theory if you do this right and you and
so if you go to work for Citadel or 72
stop this nonsense about caring about
discounted cash flow
valuation you're a Trader if you're good
at pricing and you get convergence
you're going to make your money no
matter what the market
does
so if you look at the choices here and
you look at what can I do you you're
already going to see that depending on
who you are and what you're attaching a
number to you might choose valuation
sometimes and pricing other
times and as you do all of this remember
to to Value something and I'm going to
State the obvious you need cash
flows from that so I can value Equity I
can value a business I can value a
bond so a few years ago I wrote a piece
on my blog and I wanted to answer a
question once and for all that I've been
asked repeatedly since
2008 November now the question was is
Bitcoin under or overvalued it drw me
crazy and finally said you know what I'm
going to answer it for the ages and from
now on whenever you ask me the question
I'm going to send you the link to this
post okay and I broke down investments
into four groups the first are assets
assets generate cash flows can be a
business can be a
stock the second are commodities
is oil undervalued overvalued God only
knows maybe I could build a macro model
with demand and supply for all people
try but they fail
miserably it's priced based on demand
and supply and mood it's up today why
not because there's less oil coming out
of the ground but because the fear of
tariffs is driving the price of oil up
so now oil is up for pricing reasons
Commodities can generally be priced
what about
currencies what what is the dollar under
or
overvalued I don't know it's I can tell
you what this under overprice there an
exchange rate that reflects it and today
it's gone up because again it's a tariff
dry maybe it's you know it's it's a
pricing
judgment and a
collectible can only be priced any of
you baseball card collectors
Beanie Baby collectors condolences these
are Collectibles right what's the most
famous and long-standing collectible of
all
gold you go back thousands of years
people have had gold in fact I've been
interested why did they pick that
element out of all of the others so what
is it that made gold the choice what are
the things they look for you think
inflation no no that that comes from it
they picked it they weren't thinking
infl it predates currencies remember
that right people use gold before there
currencies first is its physical
qualities right it you can melt gold you
can reform it so it's it's it
essentially Outlast other things and you
can that's why gold coins put in a
pharoh sto tomb you can go in 2,000
years later it's still gold coin so and
it's relatively scarce you don't want to
pick something which you can get all
over the place so has it held its
collectible yeah that's a good
collectible so the qu you can answer the
question because I'm sure your friends
your relatives ask you about Bitcoin
because you have an MBA and they assume
you can tell them when to buy
Bitcoin what's a question you have to
first ask about Bitcoin it's definitely
not an
asset is it a commodity not really
blockchain might lead to Ether which
might be a commodity but bit Bitcoin is
either a currency or a
collectible so to decide whether it's an
under or overpriced currency the
question you have to ask is is it a good
currency so let's step back again from
the Bitcoin frenzy and think about what
is it that makes a currency a good
currency Jessica do you have any
currency in your pocket today
see but you have your Apple pay and know
presumably you got digital currency in
US dollars right what do you what do you
carry around this currency um just and
what do you use it
for to buy things let's not forget that
one of the biggest reasons we have
currency we want to buy things right buy
lunch pay for our
Uber so good currency is a medium of
Exchange
what the other characteristic of good
currency so so that goes to the first
one because they don't accept it then
fails
fundamentally it has to hold its value
right I'll give you my example of a good
currency I don't go to Switzerland that
often it's a little boring but I don't
but I do and I remember about six seven
years ago I went to Switzerland I put a
then I used to care currency you to
convert now I no longer do that but at
100 swis
Franks and I was leaving I put in my
pocket and I put I I think I was wearing
not jeans but actually some dress pants
which I hardly ever wear so I put in my
pocket I forget about it I don't even
throw it in the wash disgusting but I
kind of hung it up a year later I pull
the pants down again occasion for dress
pants again I put my hands in my
pocket and have 100 Swiss fracks happen
to be in Switzerland again
but you know what bought about the same
things that it did a year ago because
it's a currency with almost no inflation
and it's also a currency that if ID gone
into a New York bank I could have
converted the hundred SS Franks into US
dollars because it's a freely
exchangeable currency it's a good
currency Indian
[Music]
rup in
India acceptable for the most part
unless you have the wrong denom ation in
the wrong time it tells you something
about Fiat currencies right they ride on
what the government says is acceptable
but I still remember I left India a long
long time ago 1979 I was in Mumbai
airport it's called Bombay Airport
that's how far long ago it was it a
different name for it I left you go
through immigration and you were in the
international section I went into a
store and I wanted to buy something and
they said they take only US dollars I
was still on IND
soil but they said the line for using
Indian Rupees is done you're now in Us
doll
territory and if you fly to the US with
thousands of rupees in your pocket and
you try to pay for something I don't
think even if you walk into the
Lexington Avenue Indian stores that they
will take it so it's it's a medium of
exchange as long as you stay in India
and if I put a 100 Indian rupees in my
pocket and I forget about for year odds
are it'll buy about 5 or 6% less than it
did a year ago not as good as the
Continuum of currencies before you
complain about the Indian repat thank
God you don't have a th000 Venezuelan
Boulevard in your paret right first is
it a medium of exchange even in
Venezuela they probably said do you have
some lettuce instead of this and it'll
hold its value a little better than the
no so as a medium of exchange it fails
and then as a store of value God only
knows right so even in Fiat currencies
you can see you can be anywhere from the
Swiss frank to the Venezuelan bouevard
so where in this
continum would you put
Bitcoin when was the last time anybody
in this
room use Bitcoin to pay for
something nobody you know how often I
ask this question you did Julie were you
work in Silk Road or something
something okay
but I asked this question of people who
are bit coin enthusiasts people who say
that Bitcoin is the next great
thing thousand people in the room I
never show up in person I'm afraid of
these people I always say online only
and the question ask is how many people
in this room you'd be amazed at how few
people who claim to be true believers in
Bitcoin have actually used
Bitcoin in a transaction and there's a
reason for that
right walk into a Starbucks let's say
Starbucks decides to accept Bitcoin try
to pay for a venting
cappuccino with Bitcoin think about the
process that get started first remember
it's not a physical wallet and physical
money or not even like Apple pay there's
a digital wallet where you supposedly
have Bitcoin that has to get magically
transferred to the Starbucks digital
wallet and somebody's got to check
whether both of you really are one of
you has the money and the other is
receiving so to get this transaction
consummated what has to happen a
Ukrainian minor I'm not talking about a
person D but a gets on a computer and
tries to know guess a n digigit
mathematical number and if they get it
right you you can get your cappuccino if
they don't good luck with that comes up
with a currency like that that's an
incredibly inefficient way to get
transactions done but you know why it's
designed that way right you know when
Bitcoin came into
be paper written by SE Nakamoto that I
you know pseudonym for that fat guy in
Cleveland in a basement I guess know we
nobody really
knows November of 2008 you're all too
young to remember what November of 2008
looked like but it was a scary time we
trusted no one right we lost tra trust
in Banks and governments it was born in
a moment of
paranoia and I describe it as a currency
created by the paranoid for the paranoid
if you trust no one you got to run this
n-digit
number the reason you accept a $20 bill
is because there is this trust built in
right even a $100 bill that trust breaks
down you try to pay with a $100 bill in
a store in New York they won't take it
why because if enough of that currency
is
counterfeit they're not sure trust is
the lubricant that allows us to get
convenience and Bitcoin is not a very
good currency
is the response always but they're only
21 million units scarcity alone doesn't
create a good currency if scarcity alone
determined dog poop would be a currency
too there's only a limited amount of dog
poop I know dogs keep creating more but
you know you I mean you can't use
scarcity the argument this is why we're
valuable the fallback position of course
is Bitcoin is a collectible
yeah back to something you said earlier
why would why is gold a collectible and
not a commodity
because what percentage of gold in the
world you think is held I mean it's used
as a commodity in some things as a
commodity and what percentage of gold do
you think is held because people want to
hold it as portion of their wealth
answer most of it is so it can play the
role of commodity and there are some
things that gold is useful same thing
with diamonds right they use diamonds
for some sharp you know some but most of
the diamonds we see are essentially Di
is being held because people think it'll
hold its value
yes was backed by a commodity like if I
were to consider gold as a commodity
then the currency should be valued right
like we can value the currency you can
price the currency against gold you're
talking about the gold standard yeah so
it was just then gold became the base of
currencies it essentially kept
currencies it was a way of creating a
good currency because what did
governments do they pre-committed they
said look what kills currencies is US
printing more money but because we can't
print more money it's a way in which it
kind of built the
trust so let's take the other argument
for for Bitcoin which is a millennial
collectible why because you're 30 years
old and you get scared you don't want to
buy gold because that's what your
parents did you buy Bitcoin the question
is is it a good
collectible what makes for a good
collectible let's take gold it's staying
power right it's a good collect because
it's always been a good collectible
you're saying don't Collectibles that
start off good always stay good I gave
you the Beanie Baby example there are
people probably with their addicts
stuffed with Beanie Babies that they
bought at the peak of the of that boom
were saying what the heck do I do with
these damn things
now it's got staying power and here has
the second characteristic you look for a
collectible why do people hold gold or
some people I don't hold gold but there
are people who gold bugs invest in gold
with what what is it that leads people
to buy gold I think it's a safe haven
it's a safe haven from what so one is
Crisis but the second is that you no
longer have faith in paper currency
right if you lose faith in paper
currency you go to Gold it's always been
true that's why inflation people go to
Gold I don't trust this paper you
printed off because it seems to lose
value a good collectible holds its value
when Financial assets melt down
go back through every crisis in history
and you see that gold if it doesn't go
up at least holds its value so in the
first three months of 2020 during that
covid crisis where the S&P 500 was down
33% gold was up 2% saying only 2% hey
come on everybody else is losing 33% be
happy that you're up
2% Bitcoin first we can't check staying
power yet it's been around only 16 years
and it's it's tough to pass judgment and
staying power but I can check to see
whether it's been a good collectible in
terms of what it does during crisis
remember those 3 months in 2020 when
gold was up 2% everything else was
melting down 33% down there you does
anybody remember what Bitcoin did during
those 3
months it was down
57% when stocks came back by 35% Bitcoin
was up 60% you see where this is going
right Bitcoin through its entire history
including today
has behaved like very risky
stock I'm going to talk you I mean you
can claim that anything is a collectible
but so far at least Bitcoin has been a
terrible collectible so if you're paying
what 97,000 for Bitcoin my question to
you is if it's a bad currency it's an
inefficient currency and a bad
collectible what are you paying $997,000
for that's my problem with Bitcoin it's
not that I can't make an argument for
cryptocurrencies of crypto Collectibles
remember those nfts for a while that
were taking
off 302 ad for something you get the
original ad it's it's again a
collectible argument I'm willing to
listen but the question is will it have
staying power go ahead julan could
thetically
go like it seems you're looking with
collectibl there's no Theory test right
it's whether people buy into it and for
better words when you've been around
four when you've outlasted every
currency on the face of the
earth and the question is should now is
could it happen yes tomorrow we could
say this yellow thing is not that good
let's switch to something else that's
what happened to shells right shells
were a currency on some islands until
somebody probably land with a whole
bucket load of shells and there goes the
currency or people say this is not a
great Curr so it's not I so Collectibles
and currencies can shift over time but
given it saying power I have a lot more
but with Fine Art this is often an issue
right which is you pick a painter who's
you know selling for millions of dollars
will that painting of staying power that
becomes the divining Rod whether they
going to be good at making money on
Collectibles is whether you pick those
which have staying power and if you do
odds are you going to come out of the
other end as a
success now you we're going to do
intrinsic valuation we're going to do
pricing and along the way somebody's
going to say well what about the fact
that you have you know because I said
there only three ways what about some of
the parts
valuation what about net asset value
valuation we be quite clear there might
be ways you approach valuation but
they're not approaches and and here's
what to do an asset based valuation
where you take the balance sheet and you
attach numbers to assets let's say your
collection of real estate properties
right could I could I put a number on
each real estate property yeah but there
are only two ways I can put remember I
can do an intrinsic valuation of the
property based on rental income or I can
do a pricing of the property you see
where I'm going right asset based
valuation is not a third approach it's
just a use of one of the first two
approaches when would you need it maybe
you're trying to acquire a company
because you want to break it up into
pieces maybe you're a passive investor
looking at a multi- bus company saying
maybe it's undervalued and you want to
Value the pieces so later in this class
we're going to talk about attaching
numbers to multi- business companies by
valuing the businesses individually but
it's not a separate approach valuation
it might also be something you need in
liquidation right because in liquidation
you're selling things off right now and
in fact if you're doing liquidation are
you going to do do an intrinsic
valuation of the asset or a pricing of
the asset have to do a pricing right you
got to get whatever the market will get
you so in liquidation valuation I don't
want to see intrinsic valuations of
assets I want to see pricing of
assets so I'm going to ask this question
you now but I'm going to ask you the
same question at the end of the 15th
week so kind of giving you the big
picture perspective intrinsic valuation
and pricing if you had to pick based on
what you know now it might not be
something you're you know saying I don't
know enough to make the Judgment make
your judgment based on what you know up
to now if you had to pick would you pick
intrinsic valuation or pricing are you
entering this class with a presumption
that markets are pretty good and they're
mostly efficient which is perfectly okay
as well because when I come back to you
on May 5th the last day of class and
present this you would have gone through
15 weeks of the class and let's face it
that will change you this morning in
corporate finance I said there are some
semesters where I know right from the
beginning that it's going to be a roller
coaster right this semester feels like
one of those last week was deep seek
this week is tariffs what will next week
bring I don't know but rather than view
it as a problem view it as an
opportunity this is is going to be as
long as you don't have too much money
being wasted you know wasting away it's
going to be a rocky semester right and
during that 15 weeks you're going to be
doing an intrinsic valuation of your
company and your pricing and maybe that
experience will change what you think
and I'd be interested to see how many of
you change your minds about your priors
going in and what you get
out just as a as a Side Story
here we're going to talk about applying
option pricing in the cont context of
valuation now we know what makes an
option an
option it's a leech it deres its value
from something else so when you say
something is an option you know what my
next question is going to be right what
is the underlying asset an option can't
live on its own it's got to draw its
value from something second the payoff
is contingent on something happening
with a traditional call or put it's a
strike price but know there's a
contingent payoff and usually options
have a limited life underlying asset ENT
payoff limited life but the best way to
think about options actually think in
terms of payoff diagrams if it looks
even remotely familiar you've probably
seen this in your foundations class what
makes options unique is the fact that
your losses are limited you cannot lose
more than what you paid for a call or a
put that to me is is the inside I want
you to keep in mind because when you
value an option risk becomes your ally
unlike every other type of valuation
approach
in discounted cash flow valuation you
raise risk your discount rate goes up
your value goes down in pricing you
raise the risk you pay a lower multiple
but you get an option and I raise the
risk you say this is great you say so
what is it about options and the payoff
diagram kind of gives you a clue that
makes risk your ally rather than your
enemy actor what is it about options
that makes risk your
ally I'll help you out there are two
types of risk right downside risk an
upside risk which one keeps you awake at
night and nobody lies because oh my God
my stock could go up fivefold right
that's not the risk you worry about and
what have I done with
options I've limited your downside risk
risk is one-sided right so it's not some
magic that happens the payoff diagram
that drives it now there are actually
listed options out there then we're not
going to Value them in this class
because there's an option pricing class
if you are interested in valuing
warrants and listed options and on that
you trade in the CBOE different place
for that even convertible bonds in fact
much of fixed income is option pricing
because you take a straight Bond you had
callable features convertible features
you can get that in your fixed income
class the kinds of options were're going
to Value here are actually valuations
I'm going to argue that equity in a
deeply distressed
company it's a deeply distress company
it's losing a ton of money it's got a
lot of debt so what's hanging over your
had bankruptcy right you buy equity in
the company why would I buy it you're
buying it for the same reasons you buy
deep part of the money options which is
you hope that something good will happen
then you pray that something good will
happen most of the time nothing good
happens but when something good happens
stock explodes because such a small
slice of the
company second if you're an oil company
and you have a lot of reserves that are
not viable I'm going to argue there's
optionality there they're going to apply
options to value undeveloped reserves
and how that plays out if you are a
pharmaceutical company or a technology
company with a patent an AI patent
that's right now not
viable you might have something
extremely valuable still because it's an
option those are the kinds of options
we're going to deal with but it's a tool
in my Arsenal that I will not take out
unless I absolutely have to I'm
terrified of people who pull this real
option too on every valuation that they
do it's like taking out a shotgun
because you got an ant on your front on
your on on your front pathway I think
you might be overreacting
here and the advantage of using option
pricing is you'll be able to attach
numbers to things they otherwise give up
on usually we try to Value money losing
company distress company the problem you
faces you try to do a DCF you find the
value of the firm is actually less than
the outstanding debt and that might
happen for some of your companies
you say what do I do now intrinsic
valuation dead I'll WR pricing remember
there's no positive in your you might
none of the multiples work on you those
companies options can help you put a
number on the company okay and to me the
bigger thing is even if you never apply
an option pricing model to put a number
on an asset that has option
characteristics the insight about
risk is what you take out of this if
you're going to buy equity a deeply
distressed company for God's sakes don't
make it a deeply distressed Stable
Company I'm not even sure what that
means I mean basically it's I lost 100
million last year I can guarantee you I
can lose a 100 million every that's not
what you're looking for right you want
movement because you got to get out of
the
hole so if you're a vulture investor
which you know the class of investors
investors you want the riskiest
businesses to make these bets are not
the safest business that's the kind of
insight you want to get out of this and
finally the disadvantages of option
pricing is we have option pricing models
out there I'm sure you've seen even if
you don't remember the black schs model
came about 1971 one of the you know it's
a clean model in terms of applying a
number but it was designed for
short-term listed options on traded
stocks we're going to take those models
and use them to Value the class of
options we talked about are called real
options which are often are 10 or 15
year options and things that are not
traded when you're pushing these models
to the limits and perhaps even Beyond of
what you can use so you're going to see
pricing models kind of start to fray at
the
edges and there's always a risk of
double counting what does that mean I've
seen analyst value a company with a
valuable
pattern a drug pattern that's working
its way through the pipeline they give
the company a high growth rate because
they think the pattern will make it
through the pipeline and come up with
the value for the company then once
they're done with the value they'll pull
out my book to the options chapter and
value the patent as an option and add it
on top of your discounted cash flow
valuation you've just double
counted if you want to count the option
through your growth rate and cash flows
do so or value it separately but you
can't do both so there is a danger of
double counting but I think stepping
back and keeping perspective of there
are only two three ways next time you
see a valuation model think of the
bucket you're going to put it
into because that's a critical part of
this process so that's the intro you can
put it away now because I'm going to
start in the first packet if you didn't
bring it don't worry about it
because not the end any questions on
just the approaches putting a number in
something if you can come up with some
creative way of putting a number that I
haven't thought about let me know and
I'll think about which bucket to put it
into but trust me if you think long
enough it's going to go into one of
these three
buckets so what I'd like to talk about
for the next 13 seconds sessions is the
basics of intrinsic valuation so let's
set the
table discounted cash flow Valu the
intrinsic valuation trying to Value an
asset based on its cash flows growth and
risk so when you talk about fundamentals
and you truly mean it that's what I hear
right so for cash flow generating assets
the discounted cash flow valuation is a
way of estimating it's not the only way
there might be others but it's a way
that we've developed and refined
primarily in the last 100 years
but intrinsic valuation models predate
the DCF right people came up with cash
ways of bringing in cash flows growth
and risk so we shouldn't think we
invented intrinsic
valuation it's always been around so I'm
going to show you the two most common
forms of intrinsic value of of
discounted cash flow valuation one of
these you might have never seen before
but it's something that people use
implicitly the most common way in which
you see discounted cash flow valuation
you take the expected cash flows keyword
is expected across all scenarios is the
expected cash flow and you discount them
back at a risk adjusted discount
rate that's what the DCF I'm sure you've
seen before there's a second way of
approaching discounted cash flow
valuation that you almost never see and
you'll see in a moment why instead of
using expected cash flows use what I
call certainty equivalent cash flows say
what the heck are certainty equivalent
cash flows have you ever seen this game
show called let's make a deal with hoe
mandal you have't you should watch it
here's how the game show goes I'll go to
to to to a type of thing you see on the
show there'll be two suitcases up on the
on the
screen one suitcase is a million dollars
the other suitcase is nothing you're a
contestant say come on
down so Julian you're going to be my
contestant come on down million dollars
or nothing you pick one suitcase
but I'm going to offer you cash to not
even
try right so so don't think too long
this is not an intellectual exercise an
exercise and so what's the expected
value of playing the
game 50% of a million which is 500,000
right so I'm going to start with
300,000 would you take 300,000
guaranteed and walk
away 350,000 you see what what the is
going to depend the more risk averse you
are the less money you take and if you
say I'll take only 500,000 you're risk
neutral that's really it's really if you
want to see risk conversion actually on
the
stage I've never seen an episode where a
contestant has gone all the way up to
the expected value I mean there variance
of how much lower a certain equivalent
is like Howe Mandel playing games with
so you want to Value Coca-Cola you do
the expected cash flows in your one are
those expected cash flows risky yes so
how Mel says what would you take as a
certain cash flow and you do this with
year one year two year three how he's
got to be at your back and call but when
you're done you now have certainty
equivalent cash flows if you have
certain equivalent cash flows what's the
discount rate you should apply on them
the risk-free
rate now do you see why nobody does this
how he's not at your back and
call and this comes an exercise and hand
wve but implicitly people do this
whenever I hear the word conservative
and some of you going to turn in
valuation I'm just being conservative
what are you doing you're adjusting your
cash flow below the expected value
because you want to be conservative
don't and here's why because if you do
that and then you use a risk adjusted
discount trade you've double counted
risk one of the curses of teaching this
class is Warren Buffett is out there
saying things that people bring into
this
class one of the things he's supposed to
have said is that he doesn't like baers
we know that that he uses a risk-free
rate to discount cash
flows people come and say Warren Buffett
uses the risk free rate why shouldn't I
use the risk free rate most famous value
investor of all time and I said have do
you know what Warren Buffett is
discounting with that risk create he
uses a measure of cash flow called owner
earning which is starts with net income
but counts only the net income that he
thinks
is countable he doesn't want speculative
net income so already what's he doing
he's basically doing some kind of
certain equivalent without har Mandel
saying this is my net
income he adds depreciation subtracts
capex but basically he's starting with
not a cash flow that's an expected cash
flow but his version of
a certainty
equivalent if you want to play that game
by all means do so but remember why you
using the risk rate it's not because
it's your required rate of return but
because you've adjusted the cash flow
for your
risk that's discounted cash flow
valuation I'm going to use that as my
vehicle to kind of put some propositions
on the table that I think are obvious
but might as well be remembered so when
I posted last week and
Invidia Nvidia bulls have replaced Tesla
Bulls now as some of the most irrational
people on the face of the Earth in fact
the minute you poing in video you know
it's coming I got like 3,000 comments on
it on different platforms most of them I
don't read but basically the one trick
ponies basically there a
and and among the many insults they
throw at me none of which F me is
they'll call me a theorist you're a
valuation theorist I have to laugh
because I know how little Theory there
is in the class you know what the theory
of this class is it's that equation
right there it's one equation that's my
entire class the entire class is about
coming up with better ways of estimating
expected cash flows and better ways of
adjusting my discard rate for
risk that's all EV valuation one
equation and it's it's an incredibly
powerful equation that I can use to
bring home lot of big lessons about
valuations so I want somebody to be my
guinea pig on this Jessica s here in the
first row I'm going to make you my guine
pig I'll make you look really good don't
worry don't ignore all those other
currency notes
there so empty envelope sleeves are
rolled up I'm not a magician I'm putting
a $20 bill in the envelope ready for the
first question how much would you pay
for this envelope
how much would I pay up to $20 I'm glad
you said up to $20 not $20 exactly right
you saw me put it it you know most
people just say $20 and if you pay $20
for an envelope with there's $20 in it
what do you walk away
with an envelope let look at this crappy
envelope I've written so much on
it first rule evaluation if you know the
value of something always start your
bidding at I'm glad you said a lower
number because people are confused lower
or higher
maybe this is not the class for you
right so you're the right class you said
so you pass the first test but this is
an easy asset value if I put it up for
auction we're going to end up at roughly
$20 so let's see where there I'm going
to try to get you to pay more so I'm
going to start adding stuff to this and
let's see if it makes a difference all
these neat cards I don't know which one
to put in first let's start with this
one first what does it say control
control I'm adding control control to
the $20 the envelope was worth $20 but
now I've added control to it how much
did you pay for this envelope now that
control
$90 control over what does that mean
great question and I wish more people
ask this question especially when their
m&a Bankers put a 20% control premium
this is like standard practice in m&a in
fact I tried this with a group of
Goldman Sachs m&a Bankers they were
seasoned bankers for a re-education camp
and one of them offered me 25 you know
what I did I sold them the
envelop he said and mean I said now that
it's your own money you feel the pain
right because you paid $5 for a 3x5 card
that I stole from a stack
upstairs and I wrote the word
control you see where this is going next
right let's start adding more
interesting stuff and I'll leave the big
things for later what does it say brand
name brand name that's a big thing
marketing you say this is amazing brand
name I'll add that but it's a 3x5 card
with the word brand name on
it Synergy I can put that in there too
magical I'm sorry can
I I don't think so what about
AI
there I call these weapons of mass
distraction you know why because they
show up after you've done evaluation
what about control what about brand name
what about great
management and if you're really
desperate I'll add the word that I think
will help you get over the what does it
say right strategic most dangerous word
in rent business you put it in
there Weapons of Mass distraction
because they used to justify paying an
extra
amount so I'm
use that as my first pro in fact the
last thing I was going to put was China
because until for the last 20 years you
put china into your story there goes
your value through the roof I had to
scratch it out and put
India because the CH and this is a
problem with weapons of mass distraction
they can help you today they can work
against you
tomorrow but they thrown in there to
justify pay more yeah isn't also the
assumption that all of these additional
things like brand name Etc like they're
already part of the expected cash no no
wait wait I haven't even deal so that's
a different question I'm going to create
the first proposition which is called
the it proposition the two other things
I had were two other currency notes one
is for 500 Indian rupees and I was going
to put it in envelope and ask how much
would somebody pay and hope they didn't
check the year it's a 2008 500 rupee
note it's just a piece of paper not even
very good toilet paper would use it the
other is a a $100 trillion
note from the bank of
Zimbabwe this is right before they
change the currency to something else
because when the inflation gets so high
you keep adding zeros you
know but my point is that people throw
these words because they want you to pay
a premium and not ask why so here's my
first proposition it's called the it
proposition if it does not affect the
cash flows and it does not affect risk
can we please stop talking about
it let's go back to control right Julian
what's the value of control the True
Value control not the 20% Banker thing
what's the value controlling a
business you run the business right and
maybe you'll run it differently than the
existing people running the company
you're already there to Value control
then I've got to value a business twice
once with the existing Management in
place once with you in place and
assuming you can do the right thing
things you get a higher value that's the
value of control we're going to come
back to this but we've already
established the foundations for when
control is worth nothing what kinds of
companies is control worth nothing
in when no when a company's already
perfectly managed and perfectly run
right what the heck are you going to
change do you think there's a value of
control in Invidia I'd be struggling to
find a value of control when You' taken
a company that's increased its market
cap by 3 trillion Lucio at least until
last Friday was considered to be the
greatest CEO to ever walk the face of
the earth that could
change so what what's the
value of
synergy don't give me the 2 + 2 is equal
to five crap that sometimes gets fed out
of glasses what's the essence of synergy
two entities come together and they're
able to do something that they could not
have done as Standalone entities
is there yeah you can have a two
companies come together maybe in the
same business when they come together
they can cut cost because they've over
couldn't have done it the Standalone
companies a US consumer product company
buys an Indian consumer product company
it opens up a new market is able to grow
in markets it couldn't grow before
that's Synergy we're going to Value
Synergy but it requires us to be
explicit about not just Synergy as a
word but what does is it
me come back and talk about brand name
and those of you in marketing welcome to
take issue with it but if you truly have
a brand name it should show up in your
pricing power your margins and your cash
flows fact we're going to value
burkenstock a company that's all
intangibles great management brand
name celebrities love it and Barbie wore
it in the movies it pushed up the
revenues 30% that summer and we're going
to Value each piece
my point is that these it's not that
these words don't have value but if you
do your intrinsic valuation correctly
they should already be in there it's a
sloppy way of adding things afterwards
because you forgot to deal with them
first yes SC I'm just curious when you
talk about like um the India or China
premere yeah are you assuming that it's
not longer going to impact cash because
you already no it's because you were too
lazy to bring in the cash flows you just
want to pay the premium first hope the
bigone Market takes care of your mistake
this is why Weapons of Mass distraction
are so dangerous is because you let the
word Drive what you pay and then you say
oh there's a big Market out there I'll
figure out a way to cover what I paid
and by then it's too late it's exactly
my problem with AI is AI going to be a
big Market I believe
so but does that mean I'm going to pay
tens of billions of dollars for you
because you're an AI company not so fast
right that's what intrinsic valuation
for it's not saying that India is not a
big Market to be in but says let's be
more explicit about what exactly you're
going to do that that's going to create
the cash
flows the followup that is what I call
it don't be a wh proposition and many of
you I want you to remember this because
two or three weeks in the class you're
going to say so uncertain I want to go
pick a nicer company to Value you're all
going to end up at craft timeses and
Coca-Cola because hey don't be a wor
there's uncertainty guess what everybody
valuing this company faces uncertainty
so right now you say I don't feel like
valuing inidia with this deep seek thing
on nobody feels like valuing in viia
right
now F through that that because all of
you will face it as you value company
how the heck do I know what's going to
happen nobody does make your best as to
the third proposition is what I call the
DU proposition it's named after my
daughter who's now 30 but this was when
she was 15 16 still at home to have
family dinners and I had the singular
Misfortune of sitting across the dinner
table from her and topic of conversation
would come up but I thought it's
something valuable to add to the
conversation I'd open my mouth which you
look across and say Dad duh he might a
contempt that oozed out of it was so
much that I stopped talking for like 2
years I think she kind of gone past that
face now she actually talks to me and
she doesn't but the D proposition is
reserved for a special subset of
questions I get on valuation here's
other the questions will go I'm valuing
a money losing company I expected to
lose money
forever what valuation model you think
will work best on this company you feel
like slapping the person around the face
saying wake up you have a money losing
company you expect to lose money forever
they should be paying you not the other
way around what happened after the
German reunification of the troyan start
the East German companies they thought
they could sell they actually end up
paying the West German companies to take
them off their
hands so we Bing a company which has
negative cash flows far as the I can
don't intellectualize this question
saying what kind of company would that
be a company with a broken business
model with no way
out company like Movie
Pass did any of you guys subscribe to
Movie Pass when it a business Rand do
you remember in movie pass I project
Movie Pass tell me how it worked what
did you have what what what did the
subscription look like $20 something no
$9.99 and you could watch as many movies
as you wanted in any theater you wanted
and Movie Pass would pay the theater and
might remember looking say how the hell
do you get away with this business model
I mean how much does a movie ticket cost
in New York City now
$20 $9.99 you can watch 10
movies every was like who would be
stupid enough to come up with a business
model like this one and then I got the
answer the CEO of the company came on
CNB said I see how somebody can be
stupid enough to come cuz here's how he
justify model he said the average
American goes to one movie a month the
average movie ticket in America cost
$7.50 we're making $249 on the average
American this is a great business
model what's wrong with this
Logic the average American is not
subscribing to movie pass it
is and so it's people like my son you
know how many movies he went to last
month 23 movies he waits till his two
little kids are off to and sleep and he
goes and watches a movie he he works at
Disney claims this is work for him get
the competition held on but he was a
movie pass subscriber and I said Ryan
singlehandedly you're driving the
company into
bankruptcy but here's the scary thought
the company lasted like four years burn
through $2 billion of venture capital
cash and I want to get my hands on the
list of people in inv in this company
because these people should not be
allowed to invest in a business ever
again which brings me to the final
proposition which is the don't free card
proposition some of you going to pick a
company going to estimate cash flows for
next year it's going to be negative year
two you're going to be negative and oh
my God this is Movie Pass again don't
give up so easily there are companies
which can have negative cash flows up
front which can still be valuable
companies because the cash flow as long
as the cash flows later in the process
are positive and disproportionately
positive do you see why
disproportionately positive cuz you lose
a billion in year one you got to make 5
billion in year 10 to make up for it
what kinds of companies are we talking
about here negative cash flows up
front any young company because if you
take a mature pharmaceutical company
this is not going to a young
pharmaceutical company young technology
company young infrastructure company
don't give up too
quickly so the last the next three pages
you already saw as part of the which is
when you sit down to Value company
you're going to have to make choices are
you valuing the equity in the company in
which case you focus on cash flows
equity and discount cost of equity or
you discounting the entire valuing the
entire firm you take the cash flows
which are pre- Deb cash flows and
discount them back at the cost of
capital so on Wednesday when we start
I'm going to talk about this process of
two because basically there are two ways
you can attach a value to equity right
you can take cash flows Equity discount
the cost of equity or you can value the
entire firm and arrive at the value of
equity which is what we tend to do in a
lot of should you get the same answer
and if you don't get the same answer
what could cause it that's going to be
the question we start with on
Wednesday but we set the table so
Wednesday we're going to dive into
actually starting to estimate risk free
rates and risk premiums he's saying
estimate risk free rates in some
currencies it's an estimation process
there's no given number so I'll see you
on Wednesday
how
very early stage